admit it the best part about halloween
is the costumes
and we asked you guys to send us your
ultimate costume creations
using the hashtag drewscarymore
we got so many amazing submissions so we
wanted to honor some of our faves
with some prestigious awards yes
and here to help me out is my
emmy-winning
tv personality and all-around adorable
human co-pilot ross matthews
[Applause]
you're a twister sister i'm dizzy i'm a
dizzy twister is what i am
and there's a 100 chance of humidity up
in this costume right now i just gotta
say
oh my god there's a cow on your head
yeah you know why because there's high
stakes
[Laughter]
so our first award ross to congratulate
other people
on their fabulous duds is going to go to
best group costume
and in picking the winner we really
looked for overall cohesiveness
and equal dedication from all parties
now ross will you do us the honor please
i have the envelope right here all right
and the winner for best
group costume is jeanette emily and dawn
from ontario canada addresses the iconic
characters
from beetlejuice look at them
i mean how fabulous are they you guys
are
amazing oh my goodness congratulations
don tell us about your costumes
well thank you so much for this award um
so we have been friends for like over 30
years we're huge
80s girls we love beetlejuice
i saw an idea online i asked if my girls
could help me out
and they said yes my our heads are made
out of paper mache
my teeth are made out of popcorn so
it was really a group effort and we're
so honored to be here
wow wow wow congratulations
so well deserved and thank you ladies i
hope you can display your trophy with
pride
and it is an honor to give you this
thank you
thank you thank you congratulations
really impressive okay our next category
is
best makeup here we looked for
meticulous detail and creativity
so ross please reveal the winner
the winner for best makeup is viviana
from
san diego california a mystique the
marvelous movies and comics
oh my god
i mean viviana seriously i've i've
i've been around the block this is super
impressive
how do you do it um so it's actually
silicone
um we got these little silicone kits
that you originally make like scars or
like cuts with
um but i decided to use it to make these
scales
um and hand carve them all on my face
like one by one
it overall takes like three to four
hours in order to do it
um and then going with the paint and
then the um
eye shadow and uh trying to like give it
more dimension and
uh fluidity throughout the entire face
well
i think this award is incredibly well
deserved what do you think ross i think
when you went in oscar one day for
makeup you better thank drew that's what
i say
thank you i do believe that you should
take this award
and say i am very talented
and i have this award to prove it and
it'll be the first of many i believe
thank you so much thank you well done
well well deserved some talented viewers
drew
and we're not done yet no our last
category is best commitment
here we look for someone who really
absorbed the character and went
all out with their creations so for our
final award ross take it away
best commitment the award goes to
from houston texas lauren as vincent van
gaal
wow i know
i know hello you are committed
uh lauren i absolutely
love you tell us about your costume
okay so i have always loved vince van
gogh since
elementary school art class and i was
listening to his autobiography one
day and i just felt inspired in the
moment so i took a denim jacket
and a straw hat from my closet my little
brother's prom tuxedo shirt
and some face paint and voila vincent
and lauren what are you painting so
i painted something extra special just
for you drew it's you
in your halloween costume
oh lauren you're talented and funny my
most favorite potent combination thank
you
you deserve this trophy and i love you
for bringing the van gaal
yes then go girls you've been good good
go girl thank you lauren well thank you
to
everyone who sent in their pictures and
be sure to check out
the drewberrymore show.com for
all of our standouts
you